marketing is about values if you want
people to talk about your business and
you have to give them a reason to care
if you're an ordinary company with an
ordinary message you are going to get
lost in the shuffle people will not pay
attention to you and if you're wondering
why you're not getting more
word-of-mouth why people aren't talking
about you it's probably because you
haven't given them a reason to talk
about you if you're just ordinary you're
not going to get people saying how
extraordinary you are so you have to
change your message most entrepreneurs
start off at the basics they talk about
what they do the next level up is
talking about the features the benefits
that you can offer them and then the
next level up is thinking about what you
stand for what you believe in what makes
you who you are people want to know that
and that is a message that is spreadable
so you cut grass or living most
entrepreneurs would say hey I cut grass
I can cut your grass for you it's going
to cost 30 bucks a cut the next I level
up is talking about the benefits that
you can offer them you're not cutting
grass that's not your service you're
saving them time you're making them look
good you're making their neighbor's
jealous those are the benefits but the
next level up is giving them a reason to
care about you as a company what do you
stand for pick one word that defines who
you are and what your business is all
about say it's family family is our one
word that's something that you believe
in that's something that to your core
you believe in bring that to your
business you treat your customers like
family you don't have to talk about we
provide amazing service saying things
like we treat our customers like family
that explains it on a much more powerful
and emotional level talk about how you
would cut somebody's grass look after
their lawn like it was your own or like
it was your mother's line that shows on
how much care you have into it
it makes them feel something and makes
them emotionally involved and attached
to your business where if you just say I
cut grass you're not going to get the
business so think about what that one
word is for you what defines who you are
as an entrepreneur and what your
business is all about make it powerful
make it meaningful when you see that
wardha should strike up emotions within
you and if you can get that feeling then
your customers will as well they'll
catch it like a fever and then they'll
tell their friends about it they'll tell
the community about it you're giving
them a message that they can spread and
so they'll spread it it's worth taking
some time tomorrow tonight to figure out
what you stand for as a business and
from there everything else will flow
otherwise if you just keep going as is
you're going to continually wonder why
people don't get what you do why people
don't spread the word about you why
you're not getting more word-of-mouth
business why you're not getting repeat
customers it's not important make your
message important make it spreadable
make it outstanding make it different
and people will talk about you believe
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes you want to do more for you and
I want to hear what you have to think
what did you like about this video
please leave it in the comments below
and if you have a question for your own
company I'd love to try to answer it
leave a comment and I'll get back to you
with the video reply thanks guys we'll
see you soon